were you evicted during the moratorium
eight news now week covering
real estate housing issues during our
home week focus
south carolina democratic congressman
james clyburn points to court records
which reveal that some large corporate
landlords have evicted many tenants
during the pandemic that is despite the
cdc's eviction moratorium
he heads a congressional committee which
is investigating that matter
congressman clyburn says the las
vegas-based siegel group
filed around 570 eviction orders during
the moratorium
that is despite receiving millions of
dollars in federal rental assistance
money
congress has taken action to ensure that
reynolds
experience and hardship can receive
financial help
to stay in their homes of course the
ultimate recipient
of these funds are the landlords
to whom rent is paid the federal
moratorium runs out this weekend siegel
group will still have to provide more
information on
how many evictions they followed through
with to the committee
if you are in danger of being evicted
there are resources
we have information at eightnewsnow.com